melesse et avoue deuxième partie de la
bo est libre effectivement après les
attentats de samedi il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine avec nous sur ce plateau à
la chrétiens député-maire les
républicains de vesoul et frédéric
paillard secrétaire du syndicat alliance
bourgogne franche comté
thierry falconnet maire socialiste de
chenôve et éric delzant préfet de la
région bourgogne
on l'annonçait avant de commencer cette
deuxième partie un des faits bien sûr
qu'on voit en transparence dans tous ces
événements c'est bien sûr des phénomènes
de radicalisation un des points je
parlais tout à l'heure de ce grand
rendez vous entre les maires et le
président et le gouvernement merkel à
paris cette semaine
c'était le sentiment de certains maires
de dire on voit dans nos villes des
lieux des gens qui se radicaliser et on
se sent finalement assez désarmés c'est
quelque chose que vous avez vécu qui
s'est passé dans votre ville comment
vous le vivez ça oui je pense que
beaucoup d'élus locaux maintenant ont
une expérience sur ce sujet très
particulier moi je suis dans la
discrétion
parce que je ne souhaite pas stigmatiser
je ne souhaite pas paniquer non plus les
gens mais j'ai un travail très étroits
comme l'a dit monsieur le préfet avec
les services territoriaux qui on est je
dois le reconnaître une connaissance
très très bonne de ce genre de dérives
et on est en lien avec eux et ils nous
disent souvent n'hésitez pas à dire à
vos mères je suis aussi président des
maires de haute saône
n'hésitez pas à appeler le service
territorial dès que vous avez un doute
sous dès que vous avez le sentiment
qu'il se passe quelque chose ça n'est
pas de la délation
ça n'est pas à revenir à des heures
sombres de notre histoire c'est
simplement une prise de conscience que
quand il arrive un problème dans le plus
petit village du département
le maire a toute légitimité pour en
toute discrétion un tel service
territorial lui faire part de son
sentiment et ensuite c'est le service
territorial qui rate votre délimitation
des rôles c'est le maire il connaît son
terrain il alerte c'est un langage lui
d'essayer de faire en sorte que ça ne se
passe plus surtout pas son boulot comme
j'ai dû tout ça tout à l'heure c'est de
mettre du lien entre les gens
d'organiser des rencontres festives
entre les habitants de créer cette
cohésion sociale mais surtout pas de
commencer à stigmatiser untel ou untel
notre travail c'est d'être le lanceur
d'alerté ensuite c'est à l'état avec de
très bons services territoriaux de mener
ou pas des investigations
supplémentaires pour savoir vraiment
quelle est la réalité des choses mais
surtout pas à nous et en même temps dans
votre zone il ya eu des jeunes qui sont
partis en syrie avec souvent la surprise
des parents ça veut dire que c'est quand
même un phénomène qui échappe totalement
à un certain nombre de fonds va dire de
seuil de contrôle ou de houe perception
il ya eu par exemple pierre chollet
originaire de port sur saône qui est
mort en syrie
il avait 20 ans je crois que c'est un
problème beaucoup plus profond que je
connais d'évoquer tout de suite les
perquisitions les radiers la
radicalisation c'est un problème
culturel très profond comment se fait-il
qu'une génération voire même maintenant
deux générations est totalement
abandonnée les symboles de la république
et ne se reconnaissent plus dans les
symboles de la république le drapeau
français la marseillaise comme vous
l'avez dit qu'il resurgit maintenant ça
n'est pas réservé à des vieux ronchon et
aux anciens combattants
f3 et à l'extrême droite ce sont des
valeurs d'actualité qui nous concerne
tous qu'on doit se réapproprier mettre
un drapeau tricolore sur sa fenêtre ça
n'est pas être un fasciste ou à un
quelqu'un de deux mauvais c'est
quelqu'un de patriotes le patriotisme
depuis de nombreuses années a été
dévalorisée et on l'a rendue synonyme de
national vous opposer les deux vous vous
opposiez sûr bien sûr moi je suis un
patriote j'aime mon pays et je veux le
faire partager à tous ceux qui y
habitent et je crois qu'il ya une vraie
révolution culturelle qui doit se mettre
en place et on doit se remettre en cause
comment se fait-il qu'un jeune de 20 ans
ce ne se reconnaissent plus dans la
république et aille chercher des choses
aussi lointaine on est aussi dans un
système sectaire c'est le même processus
qu'une secte rentrer dans ce don ce dont
cette radicalisation
c'est comme rentrer dans une secte parce
qu'on a des fragilités psychologiques et
qu'on cherche quelque chose pour se
valoriser
donc c'est tout ça qui va falloir
travailler dans les mois qui viennent
thierry falconnet ce sentiment aussi on
est là pour alerter on n'est pas là pour
intervenir vous le partagez et et vous
vous poser les mêmes questions
oui bien sûr je bien sûr nous posons les
mêmes questions ce que comme les aime je
suis chrétien nous avons
une connaissance fine de nos territoires
et le devoir d' alerte des mères nous
n'en faisons usage lorsque lorsque les
situations se présentent je n'ai pas
connaissance de deux phénomènes patent
avérée de radicalisation sur le
territoire sur le territoire de la
commune de chez nous en revanche nous
sommes très attentifs au climat général
qui qui peut par moment laisser penser
que certains jeunes dans nos quartiers
sont sensibilisés par le biais
d'internet par le biais de deux de
discussion qu'ils peuvent avoir avec
avec des jeunes qui eux sont
radicalisées peuvent être sensibles à ce
discours est celle sens aussi de tout le
travail que nous menons nous les élus
locaux sur le terrain en matière
d'éducation en matière de d'accès à la
culture d'accès au sport qui sont des
outils d'émancipation pour l'ensemble de
notre population et tout
particulièrement pour pour pour notre
jeunesse est ce qu'il est aussi question
mettant les pieds dans le plat d'emploi
de travail d'activité on parle là de
symboles de république
est ce que le terreau de cette
radicalisation ça n'est pas aussi le
désoeuvrement le chômage le sentiment
d'exclusion par rapport à une partie de
la société
falcone oui la question sociale est au
coeur de nos préoccupations
moi ce que me renvoie les jeunes avec
qui je suis en contact quasi permanent
c'est nous voulons un travail
nous voulons fonder une famille nous
voulons nous intégrer socialement
professionnellement dans la république
française dans la société française et
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
le chômage de masse que la difficulté
que l'échec scolaire sont autant de
difficultés dans nos quartiers
populaires pour donner de l'espoir et et
tracer des perspectives est vraiment le
travail que nous non
lien là aussi avec les services de
l'état dans le cadre de la politique de
la ville sont tous tendus vers ce même
objectif la faire intégrer ces jeunes
dans notre société républicaine
lorsque vous avez des français intégrés
qui ont un travail qui ont des enfants
qui partent faire le djihad
c'est pas une question d'emploi c'est
pas une question d'intégration c'est une
question culturelle
donc effectivement quand vous avez 25 %
de chômage chez les jeunes de moins de
25 ans ça pose un problème bien sûr mais
vous avez c'est le jeu supérieur dans
certains quartiers mais vous êtes
français entre guillemets j'aime pas
cette expression mais de souche qui part
tient le jihad et donc ça pose aussi une
vraie question culturelle je suis
d'accord avec vous ont plu aura de
travail pour tout le monde moi y aura
d'oisiveté et comme disait ma grand-mère
l'oisiveté est mère de tous les vices
certes sauf que vous avez aussi des gens
intégrés qui bascule et je reviens au
système des sectes les sectes c'est la
fragilité psychologique donc la
nouveauté c'est que d'âge c'est tous ces
entreprises terroristes savent détecter
les personnes fragiles psychologiquement
qui n'ont pas trop lem d'intégration qui
ont une famille mais qui sont fragiles
psychologiquement ils les détecte et il
arrive à les attirer vers eux ces
saucisses phénomène sectaire
donc il va falloir qu'on s'occupe dans
les mois qui viennent et des gens alors
bien sûr vous ne donnerez pas forcément
les chiffres mais qu'elle est est ce
qu'on peut donner un paysage de de cette
situation de la radicalisation
aujourd'hui comment est ce que
j'appréhende la question de la
radicalisation d'abord à travers sa
détection bien entendu il ya un certain
nombre de signalements qui sont faits
ces signalements ils peuvent venir
d'ailleurs de d'origines très diverses a
peut être des mères ça peut être par
exemple des principaux de collège ou des
employeurs qui nous disent tel ou d'un
clerc sera aussi que si on avait un des
clubs sportifs si telle ou telle
personne nous préoccupe par son
comportement par l'évolution de son
comportement tel monsieur ne sa bulle
salut plus les femmes
tel monsieur a changé sa manière de se
comporter donc ça ce sont des
signalements qui nous sont données et
nous avons une évaluation permanente
dans le département de la côte d'or de
l'ensemble des signalements qui nous
sont faits et chaque semaine je réuni
une cellule qui suit les cas de
radicalisation pour permettre de voir
comment précisément ça se passe
si je vous donne pas de chiffres c'est
parce que dans ces signalements
évidemment il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui ne mérite pas d'être prises
en considération et donc ce qui est
important ce n'est pas tellement le
nombre c'est l'importance des
signalements mais je peux vous assuré
qu' il n'y ait pas de cas qu il me soit
signalé qu'ils ne soient pris en
considération
est ce que vous êtes en train de dire
qu'à cause des événements de ces
semaines passées ou des mois passés il
ya un certain nombre de signalements qui
augmente et dans des proportions un
petit peu fois exagéré
bien sûr ça reste marginal et
heureusement ça n'est pas très
considérable mais c'est vrai que cette
semaine on a eu un certain nombre de
signalements qui méritent pas
honnêtement d'être d'être retenu mais ce
qui est important c'est que les
signalements qui sont significatifs sont
tous pris en compte et les services qui
ont compétence pour cela suive
j'allais dire véritablement individu par
individu
l'évolution de ces personnes après ce
qui est important c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut entreprendre ce qu'on appelle
la déradicalisation alors il ya une
action vous avez entendu que le prêt
ministre avaient annoncé qu'ils allaient
avoir une institution propre pour cela
on peut aussi mais danois ont essayé
pour l'armée ont perdu mais localement à
s'attendre de d'action moi par exemple
en côte-d'or roma engagé avec des
personnes spécialisées aussi bien
d'ailleurs
le chs de dijon qu'avec des personnes
qui ont ces spécialités professionnelles
pour recevoir et prendre en compte des
jeunes dont on nous avait signalé la
radicalisation
alors vous savez on à monsieur le maire
a eu raison de deux de parler de
problèmes de société on
aussi parfois des problèmes de mal être
terrible chez des jeunes qui présentent
des fragilités psychologiques et qui
donc sont susceptibles d'être influencés
parce que ce qu'il faut bien voir aussi
c'est que c'est souvent on voit des
évolutions de comportement chez des
jeunes qui ont été qui avait cette
fragilité là qu'ils ont pu être
influencé par cette idéologie sectaire
moi je partage tout à fait cette analyse
delà de la notion de sectarisme
avec tout ce que ça comporte de coupure
avec tout un environnement qui peut être
à la fois scolaire familial social
affectif et c'est là qu'il ya un travail
très important à mener et il est très
important de le mener avec les maires
dans le cadre effectivement de la
prévention de la délinquance dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville parce
qu'en effet c'est là qu'on peut
développer des actions collectives
chacun dans sa responsabilité je crois
qu'effectivement c'est à l'état de
d'avoir cette responsabilité là mais il
faut que ce soit fait en dialogue avec
les responsables locaux et en dialogue
avec les maires parce qu'ils peuvent
aussi nous apporter évidemment à la fois
des informations très précieuses et
aussi des initiatives locales très
important nous reste très peu de temps
il nous reste 40 secondes dans cette
émission juste ce que vous êtes tous
d'accord est ce qu'il y aura un avant et
un après c'est un moment particulier de
la société française bien sûr ça va de
soi ça va de soi on est tous marqués on
a encore ça en tête c'est clair
thierry falconnet terminée par un un
message d'espoir la france est un beau
pays est uni dans la cohésion dans la
dans l'unité nationale nous serons
relevé relevé cette situation très très
difficile que nous vivons actuellement
merci à tous les cadres d'être venus
débattre dans ce moment particulier
merci d'avoir réagi très rapidement à
notre invitation
on reprendra probablement les débats sur
les élections régionales le week-end
prochain
mais ces derniers ne nous ont montré que
beaucoup de choses pouvaient se passer
bon week end au revoir et merci au
revoir